congrats on the movie i thought it was
really well done oh great thank you we
appreciate that
uh so i want to start with um i love
learning behind the scenes
of the making of a movie uh you know the
things you don't read in the press notes
right what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of
snake eyes
oh henry's like action scenes
will probably like blow everyone's mind
because i guess he's not
you know known yet as this like action
leads
um but he is so he worked so hard
um training every day and i think the
result
really shines through um and yeah
i think the chemistry between henry and
andrew
on and off um the screen i think
is something that really um shines
through as well
i agree with you i think henry did a
fantastic job i really do
great i'm glad uh so i i am curious when
you went in to audition for this
uh did you actually think you were gonna
get it or was it one of these things are
you like
let me just try well i'm you know i'm
normally a bit part actor so
you know i do audition a lot but i never
get
the part so i kind of went in thinking
oh this is
you know a great role great script i i
you know it would be a dream role to
play
but i probably won't get it um so i was
very very surprised when uh
i got the call yo i can't imagine what
your reaction was because
it's a big hollywood movie oh yeah i
mean i still can't believe it i still
like pinch myself to this day thinking
like did i just
imagine that so yeah yeah uh so this was
as far as i know your big
first big hollywood film what do you
wish you knew
on day one that maybe you didn't know
going in
well i think maybe the fact that you
know everyone's like i was
pretty nervous going in you know because
you know henry's a
big rising star um ursula is a huge star
um but you know they're all like human
beings and they're so like down to earth
and there's no
need to feel so um intimidated um
and will that do you know the best we
can to uh bring the film to life
so we all have the same goal and
you know same aspiration and same dreams
and stuff so
yeah uh the action in the film is very
well done
and i love the fact that there's wide
shots where you can clearly see it's
the people doing these scenes not just
all stunt performers
nice um what what was
uh it like behind the scenes trying to
bring these things to life
and you know maybe can you talk about
one of the scenes that really
you know was tough i mean it was a lot
of like
hard work uh we put a lot of like sweat
and
tears and you know hard work into it um
because we want to do the film justice
and all the actors got to do most of our
stunts ourselves which was
um incredible um the scene
in the alleyway in the rain was very
hard because
it was a it was such a narrow
so that was very tricky to get the the
fight choreo
right in and also because the rain was
very very cold
and we shot it at the end of november
and
in vancouver in a very cool studio um
so i think everyone was turning slightly
blue towards the end of us
that's what's funny is the next thing i
was going to ask you about was filming
the scene in the alley with the rangers
and it looked like
what people don't realize is and maybe
you can sort of talk about it is that
making a movie is not as
glamorous as i think maybe people think
absolutely not
it's probably as fun as like it looks
but it's definitely not as
nowhere near as glamorous as people
think it is
when you talk about training for this
movie can you start to talk
talk a little bit about like what does
that really entail is it one of these
things where it's like hours a day for
months
what what was it for you so for me
because i was
um the one of the last um cast
to get cast in it um so i think the boys
trained for longer but for me personally
i trained for two
two months building up to the the
beginning of the shoot
every day with a stunt team four hours a
day
um and then i'd go home after my daily
training with the stunt team
and um practice all the the skills and
the techniques and the moves they taught
me that day
in my gym for another hour two hours
um every day so that would be what six
hours
a day uh for two months and then once we
started filming
it wasn't as regular but if i had a day
off and if the
stunting her day off we'd train together
and go through the fight choreo and
stuff so
it was it was pretty intense but it was
it was very fun
is it sort of like it is it do you still
have that muscle memory where if you
needed to go film something
you could still do it or is it all
forgotten now oh i think it's still in
there somewhere
people best not snuck up behind me in
the dark because
i don't know what i would do uh
obviously
everyone involved in this movie is
hoping to make more films
that are either sequels or connected to
gi joe or whatever it may be
what do you hope happens in future
installments what are you excited to
maybe explore with your character
uh well with my character i think
there's a lot that can be explored and
you know i'd love to explore her
backstory i'd love to explore
the relationship and i don't the the
dynamic she has with storm shadow and
snake eyes
um and i'm just very excited
to um as a fan to be able to like see
where the universe
you know goes and how it expands and how
more characters get introduced to the
universe
i'm this is a jokey question but bear
with me i am curious
so obviously um they a snake eye storm
shadow at some point they wear masks
can someone explain to me how they see
through the masks and are able to do
everything that they do that is a very
good question
i will ask them i've always wondered
it's like a tiny little
anyway i think they're like uh magic
mirrors maybe
you know it's like one one-sided thing
where
they can see you but you can't see them
okay that's actually legit um i believe
that you have spent time in tokyo
i have yes um did you if someone was
going there for the first time
what would be the thing that you really
recommend they do
it depends on what kind of stuff they
like i'm a big
um geek so i love going to like
anime shops in like shibuya and
akihabara
um i love koto so i definitely recommend
people to like
you know take a a trip out of tokyo and
go visit koto which is
a very beautiful city um yeah
uh my other thing for you is that uh i'm
curious
with i'm not talking to robert were
there do you remember if you had a lot
of deleted scenes
or any deleted scenes i think we do yeah
right can you share any oh i don't think
i'm allowed to i think
i have to wait for the the dvd um
really got it i will leave it there and
just say listen congrats
on this thought you did great i hope
it's a huge hit
thank you so much really appreciate that
thank you have a great day